SHERICE TORRES: Hello, everyone.
My name is Sherice Torres.
I'm the Global Director
of Inclusion at Google,
and I'm excited to partner
with my colleague Ruby
Chang from the GCP
K-12 Education team
to speak with you about the
role of Employee Resource Groups
in building a culture of
inclusion and belonging.
Ruby will kick off our time
together with a deep dive
into the
Women@GoogleCloud group,
and I'll give an overview
of Google's overall approach
to Employee Resource Groups.
Over to you, Ruby.
RUBY CHANG: Thank you, Sherice.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Ruby Chang.
I serve as one of the
global leads for Women
at Google Cloud,
and I also serve
as a Google Cloud Platform
for K-12 Education
lead across North America.
Our chapter of Women@ is a
global network of about 850
women and allies that are
passionate about building
a diverse and inclusive culture
where all of us can thrive
and bring our whole
selves to work.
More broadly, Women@ is
the largest ERG at Google,
with over 120 chapters
at 52 offices globally.
Our start was very grassroots.
Back when we were a small
team of what was then
Google Enterprise,
three women just
wanted to connect with
others across their team.
And even without a
designated leader,
they had a desire to
get to know one another.
So they just got started
with video meetings, which
eventually became face-to-face
lunches as the team grew,
and that eventually evolved
to the large-scale programming
that we're at today.
It has been incredibly powerful
to see this community grow
into a global network.
And looking back at our humble
roots and successful years
since then, we've
also seen that there
are times when we needed a
lot of help, when we needed
to seek out executive
sponsorship,
and times when we
couldn't find any.
What has really helped
us through all of this
is staying centered
on a mission.
We're a global network focused
on empowering, connecting,
developing, and retaining
talent within Google Cloud.
This is not just important
for the Cloud team,
but it's also aligned to
Google's ERG and Women@ goals.
We have a committed leadership
team that meets weekly,
and we get together twice
a year for an off-site.
That keeps us true and
focused to our mission.
We use that time to evaluate
the past few months,
look at the feedback, and
plan events and avenues
to bring the full
community together again.
You'd be correct to imagine that
our professional relationships
very quickly become
very personal ones,
as we dedicate time to get
to know one another better
and tap into each
other's strengths.
We have no budget,
so we rely entirely
on our commitment, our
creativity, tenacity,
and passion to get things done.
We have three pillars that guide
Women@GoogleCloud and connect
back to the heart of
everything that we do.
And as I share these pillars
and some examples with you,
I also want to share
some things that we've
learned along the way.
Our first pillar is
to raise awareness.
This speaks to raising awareness
around gender diversity
as well as promoting
talent to join and develop
with Google Cloud teams.
For example, we maintain a
[? cadence ?] with the Cloud
staffing teams and
check in quarterly,
and we have a dialogue
on how our community can
support their goals.
We want to be intentional
about creating connections
and host external recruiting
events as one avenue to do so.
That encourages industry talent
to consider joining our team.
I mentioned earlier the idea
of an executive sponsor.
At one point, we just
didn't have women leaders
to take this on with us.
But executive leadership
is crucial to ERG success,
and we're so lucky to have
Nina Harding, Google Cloud's
Chief of Global Partner Programs
and Strategy, to take this on.
And her sponsorship
and advocacy are
key to elevating the impact
of our women and allies
at the leadership level.
Our second pillar is
building the community.
It challenges us to
really consider, how do we
create a culture that
helps retain women talent
and is inclusive of
allies, especially now,
in a digital environment?
This is not something that
we can do just once a year,
checking off a box with
one event or a big idea.
We approach this as a
series of experiences,
and it requires a lot of
communication and activation
across our entire global team.
Let me take you
through one decision.
A way to represent
our unique culture
is with the brand or logo that
represents what we stand for,
so we embarked on launching
a fun logo contest.
We collected
submissions, held a vote,
and our finalist
was a great graphic
of a woman avatar with a
superhero cape trailing
behind her.
We loved it.
But we also started
hearing from our community
that perhaps this was not
the most representative icon
to represent all women in Cloud.
The avatar was slim,
had a lighter skin tone,
and was able-bodied.
And we took that
feedback very seriously.
So we opted, instead,
for a more inclusive
colorful text-based
logo that we have today,
and it was only second
by a few votes anyhow.
Outside of creative
choices, there
are a lot of logistical
decisions for a community
of hundreds of members.
So to scale, we have to be
intentional about aligning
on our communication channels.
We primarily use
Google Groups, which
functions both as our
message board as well
as our email distribution.
And this group is
intentionally created
to be a public and
not private group,
so that all Googlers
can read and engage.
It allows us to maintain an
open culture and approach
to events and discussion.
We also have an
internal web page
that serves as a home base
for upcoming activities,
past archived events, and more.
There is a unique challenge
when your team grows globally.
And in order for
that to be effective,
we really need to think global
and empower folks to activate
and organize locally.
We have an incredible network
of ambassadors who help lead
the Women@ presence in their
local home offices as part
of this effort.
We're also very proud
of our recently formed
regional chapters
in EMEA and APAC
and functional chapters that are
organizational or team-based,
like Women@Coreinfrastructure.
We tap into each
other's platforms
and connect as a stronger global
network of women and allies.
We also want to
recognize that community
is inside and outside.
There needs to be a
balance between the work
that we do here at Google
and how we share and invite
other leaders to join
us in that mission.
Last year, we partnered with
the Kellogg School of Management
to launch a global
speaker series,
where we brought
their professors who
were experts in the
field to deliver
sprints of professional
development topics.
We had about 200 members
attend each talk,
and it sparked internal
dialogue with one another,
in addition to offering external
networking opportunities.
Our third and last pillar
is empower and develop.
This is centered on
providing opportunities
for professional
development and training,
as well as supporting
the promotion of women
to leadership positions.
It is so important to create
a culture of celebration
and recognition for the growth
and accomplishments of what
we do.
Our members every day go
well beyond just our teams
or our customers.
We have an opportunity
to share knowledge, learn
from one another, and
create stronger impact when
we act together.
So every quarter, we highlight
the awesome work happening
around the world in a newsletter
and encourage recognition
across teams into our
senior leadership.
This is another place where
executive sponsorship really
comes in.
We want to lift,
amplify, and build trust
across Google Cloud.
If there's one lesson
we've picked up since 2014,
it's that we're always
learning, we're always growing,
and it never hurts to have
some fun along the way.
Looking ahead, while we're all
navigating the remote working
situation, we especially
want to lean into listening
to our community.
In March, we took steps to
re-evaluate all our 2020
programming, thinking should
we scrap and replan our events?
And if that occurred, why
don't we just ask our folks?
What's important
to Googlers now?
How do we support our women and
allies doing work from home?
After that poll, we heard
that our priority really
fell into three-fold.
One, to have a better
understanding of the company
resources available to
them during COVID-19.
So we hosted an
open Q&A dialogue
with our partners on the
People Operations team
to promote discussion
and information sharing
for the unique situations
that a lot of our members
are actively managing today.
Second, Googlers want to spend
more time with Cloud leaders,
so we launched Candid
Cloud, and opened discussion
with two regional Cloud
leaders every month.
And, third, Googlers
don't want to slow down
when it comes to internal
and external networking
opportunities.
So we always ask ourselves,
how can we integrate
this in everything that we do?
One thing we did learn that
folks really don't want right
now is another group chat.
It seems that a lot of us are
experiencing chat fatigue.
So while we're pivoting over
toward a digital workplace,
at least for now, we found
unexpected opportunities.
While the past few months have
not been easy for most of us,
in some ways it's
become easier to think
beyond the walls of our
office and come together
as one global team.
Now that you know more about
Women@GoogleCloud, Sherice,
I want to welcome you to share
more of Google's broader ERG
strategy.
SHERICE TORRES: Thanks, Ruby.
I'll start with a brief overview
of the ERG structure at Google
and the role of ERGs in
fostering a sense of community
within underrepresented groups.
I'll close with a few case
studies of how organizations
can partner with ERGs to
foster a sense of belonging,
both within
underrepresented communities
and across the company.
And just a caveat, while
we are excited to share
some of our learnings
with you today, we
are by no means
experts in this space.
Let's start with an
overview of ERGs at Google.
We have 16 Employee
Resource Groups
with over 35,000 members in
50 offices around the world.
In addition to the employees
who volunteer their time
to serve as leaders for our
Employee Resource Groups,
each of our ERGs is
supported by a team
of global and regional
community advisors dedicated
to supporting the
ERGs by driving
opportunities for
connection, personal,
and professional development.
Community advisors drive
this work in three ways.
First, they empower ERG
leaders by providing
strategic advisory support
and centralized cross-ERG
functions, such as
budgeting, governance,
and quarterly Leads Summits
to share best practices.
Community advisors help ERG
leaders to recognize and apply
the leadership
skills that they're
gaining in their community
role and apply them
to their core jobs.
They also form a bridge between
our ERGs, which typically serve
early to mid-level
career Googlers,
and executive councils
comprised of senior leaders
from each community, serving as
advocates and sponsors for ERG
initiatives, as well as
mentors for more junior members
of each community.
Second, community advisors
supplement the programs
created by local ERG
chapters with programs
designed to benefit ERG
members around the globe.
For example, community
advisors host annual Women
of Color summits,
an ERG buddy program
to assist in onboarding new
employees, allyship workshops,
and pilot sponsorship
programs to support
career progression for
underrepresented communities.
Finally, community advisors help
to strengthen Google's business
by partnering with ERG and
executive council leaders
to infuse the
perspectives and needs
of underrepresented communities
into new and existing Google
platforms, products,
and policies.
Next, I'll move
into a few examples
of how ERGs help
to foster community
within underrepresented groups.
I'll use Hola as an example.
Hola is our global ERG focused
on the Hispanic and Latinx
community, with a mission
to progress inclusion,
advancement, and representation
of Hispanic, Latinx,
and their allies across Google.
Hola fosters community
through a combination
of informal gatherings, such
as First Tuesdays, where
community members gather
for lunch at designated
cafes in each office on the
first Tuesday of each month.
They also have book clubs and
spoken-word open mic nights.
We combine the informal programs
with formal programming,
such as the annual
Hola Leadership Summit,
providing the unique
space for Hola members
to build community,
develop, and better position
each other to lead both
within and outside the context
of the Hispanic and
Latinx community.
The annual Latinas at Google
summit, a two-day event
created for Latinas by
Latinas, with the intention
of building community, providing
networking opportunities,
and developing career
growth, as well
as annual Hispanic Heritage
Month celebrations.
Hola also holds
annual service trips,
such as their 2019 volunteer
mission to Puerto Rico
to assist the community
in recovery efforts
after Hurricane Maria.
I'd like to close with two
case studies of how community
advisors partner with ERG
leaders and executive councils
to foster a sense of
belonging, specifically
by supporting underrepresented
communities in times of crisis.
My first example relates
to the Asian community.
As many of you may know,
the Asian community,
particularly in
the United States,
experience heightened xenophobia
in the context of COVID-19.
Our community advisors work
hand-in-hand with the leads
from the Asian Google
Network, our ERG dedicated
to supporting the diverse
multicultural Asian community,
and the Asian Leadership
Group, our executive council
of senior Asian Google leaders,
to provide a combination
of resources to support
the Asian community
in the midst of this crisis.
First, advisors partnered with
the Asian Leadership Group
and other Google senior leaders
outside of the Asian community
to send messages of
acknowledgment, support,
and solidarity to
Asian Googlers.
Next, we paired community
support sessions and wellness
resources for the
Asian community
with a digital AGN COVID-19
community support hub,
centralizing AGN programming,
resources, and communications
to support Asian Googlers
through COVID-19 and related
issues of racism and xenophobia.
An AGN giving
campaign was set up
to raise funds for six
US-based nonprofits supporting
Asian community relief efforts,
with Google matching up
to $10,000 in
donations per Googler.
Finally, we affirmed, along
with over 100 corporations
and partner organizations, the
COVID-19 Action Agenda penned
by Ascend, the largest
nonprofit pan-Asian organization
for business professionals
in North America.
This combination of internal
support with external advocacy
is helping to create a culture
where Asian Googlers feel
seen, connected, and supported
in the midst of crisis.
My second example relates
to the Black community.
Over the past several years,
particularly in the summer
of 2020, violent
and racist attacks
against the Black community
are forcing the world
to reckon with the structural
and systemic racism Black
people have experienced
over generations.
Specifically in the aftermath
of the murder of George Floyd,
community advisors
partnered with global leads
from the Black Googler
Network, an ERG
designed to cultivate
Black leaders,
empower communities, and
transform technology,
and the Black Leadership
Advisory Group,
our executive council of
senior Black Google leaders,
to step up for the
Black community
and reaffirm
Google's commitments
to inclusion and racial equity.
Similar to our approach
with the Asian community,
we began by acknowledging
the pain of the Black Googler
community through messages
of support from the Black
Leadership Advisory Group,
senior leaders outside
of the Black community, as well
as organic notes of solidarity
from other ERGs and
executive councils.
We're following with a series
of community support, allyship,
and anti-racism
education resources,
centering first on
supporting Black Googlers
with community-building, mental,
and physical well-being tools,
then following with a series
of company-wide and small group
sessions to assist Googlers at
every stage of their allyship
journey, specifically in the
context of racial equity.
Our internal sessions
focus on bias, privilege,
and immediate steps
Googlers can take
to show up for their
colleagues, in times of crisis
and at all times.
We followed our
internal programming
with a dedicated Search
for Racial Equity
series on the public
Talks at Google platform,
featuring experts in the field
of anti-racism, civil and human
rights.
Most importantly, we went
beyond words to concrete actions
in support of both Black
Googlers and Black communities
around the world by publicly
committing to build sustainable
equity for Google's Black+
community and to make
our products and programs more
helpful in the moments that
matter most to Black users.
You can learn more
about these commitments
at google.com/racial-equity.
I'd like to close our time
today with a definition
from the Center for
Talent Innovation.
According to the
CTI, organizations
can foster a sense of
belonging, particularly
among underrepresented
communities,
by creating a culture where all
employees feel seen, connected,
supported, and proud to be a
part of their organization.
As you can see from Ruby's
deep dive into Women@Cloud,
as well as my overview of
Employee Resource Groups
at Google, ERGs are
just one way that we
work to create a culture
of belonging at Google.
Beyond fostering a
sense of community
within underrepresented
groups, ERGs
can be a powerful tool to
drive advocacy, accountability,
and change across
your organization.
For additional learning,
you can take a look
at the Resources section of
this session on our website.
Thank you so much
for your time today.